it's an honor to do this and yes I
believe that we have to be honest with
the American people I think sometimes we
can disagree with the facts there are
certain things that we may miss we may
not fully understand when we come out
but our intentions never to lie to you
Jonathan our job is to make sure that
sometimes and you're in the same boat I
mean there are times when you guys tweet
something out or write a story and you
publish a correction that doesn't mean
that you were intentionally trying to
deceive readers and the American people
does it and I think we should be
afforded the same opportunity there are
times when we believe something to be
true or we get something from an agency
or we act in haste because the
information available wasn't complete
but our desire to communicate with the
American people and make sure that you
have the most complete story at the time
and so we do it but again I think that
when you look net-net we're going to do
our best every time we can i'm going to
come out here and tell you the facts as
I know and if we make a mistake I'll do
our best to correct it but I don't I
think that it's as I mention the other
day it is a two-way street there are
many mistakes the media makes all the
time they miss report something they
don't report something they get a fact
wrong I don't think that's always an
intern around say okay you are
intentionally lying I think we all go
try to do our best job and do it with a
degree of integrity that they're in our
respective industries do you have any
corrections that you would like to make
her clarifications or what you share I'm
Ingrid will ask away Jonathan we just
Princeton I want to get in to relitigate
the whole issue but like just take one
like the issue of Metro ridership you
may have stated about yet and at the
time the information that was provided
by the inaugural committee came from an
outside agency that we reported on and I
think knowing what we know now we can
tell that well matas numbers are
different but we were trying to provide
numbers that we had been provided that
wasn't like we made them up out of thin
air and you stand by saying that that
was the most-watched inaugural by the
aggressive sure it was the most-watched
inaugural when you look at look you look
at just the one network alone got 16.9
million people online another couple of
the network's there were tens of million
people that watch that online never mind
the the audience that was here 31
million people watched
vision combine that with the tens of
millions of people that watched it
online on a device there's it's
unquestionable I don't and I don't see
any numbers that dispute that when you
add up in tendence viewership a total
audience incomes of tablets phones on
television I'd love to see any
information that proves me that proves
that otherwise